and a good afternoon to you thank you
for joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian casadas a metro
officer finds himself on the wrong side
of the law this evening police say caleb
rogers was caught robbing the rio and he
could be linked to other armed robberies
he went before a judge this morning the
8 news now i-team's vanessa murphy first
broke this story at 8newsnow.com she
joins us live in studio with the latest
vanessa
a judge set the bail for officer caleb
rogers at 250 thousand dollars if he can
post bond he'll be on high level
electronic monitoring and banned from
the las vegas strip the judge this
morning pointing to the violence rogers
is accused of
he was brandishing a firearm threatening
multiple people on multiple occasions
that he will shoot them that he has
again metro police say one of their own
officer caleb rogers tried to rob the
rio casino early sunday morning as first
reported by the 8 news now i-team rogers
may be linked to two other casino
robberies at red rock on november 12 and
at aliante on january 6. police had
previously released these images asking
for the public's help to identify the
suspect similar
ammos similar walking
appears to be the same person that metro
has currently investigated according to
the department rogers has been an
officer since 2015 and he was assigned
to the community policing division at
bolden area command the i-team found
court documents from a 2020 divorce
where he lists multiple loans including
from money tree and dollar loan center
his public defender pointing to several
factors including his roots in the
community no criminal history and
previously stable employment but his
work as a police officer may not help
his case in court the fact that the
defendant in this case has been trained
as a police officer at the expense of
the county and has betrayed that trust
by engaging in criminal conduct
rogers is suspended without pay he faces
four felony charges including assault
with a deadly weapon the head of the
police union says the union will not
represent rogers since the alleged
crimes happened off duty and he says if
the allegations are true the union is
disgusted and disappointed by the
actions of one rogue officer back to you
[Music]